place au match des idées confrontation
de points de vue ce soir entre ferghana
diaries et la kribi romdhane
on va notamment s'arrêter sur cette
autre affaire qui va déboucher sur une
nouvelle loi la sphère sarah halimi et
la question des responsabilités pénales
eric dupond-moretti annonce un projet de
loi présenté en conseil des ministres à
la fin du mois de mai cette fois pour
dit-il combler un vide juridique
quel est ce vide une nouvelle loi
peut-elle le comble est là encore c'est
la question va en débattre avec nos
invités dans un instant d'abord ce sujet
de jonathan du priest hier place du
trocadéro près de 20000 manifestants ont
réclamé justice pour sarah halimi deux
semaines après la décision de la cour de
cassation jugeant le meurtrier de la
sexagénaire irresponsable pénalement
la colère des représentants de la
communauté juive et autres responsables
politiques ne retombe pas sous la
pression le gouvernement a annoncé
vouloir légiférer rapidement sur ce
thème
conformément à la demande du président
de la république le gouvernement
présentera fin mai en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi pour combler
le vide juridique
apparu dans la sphère sarah halimi cette
histoire tragique qui nous a tous
marqués va faire avancer notre droit le
garde des sceaux entend donc modifier
l'article l 122 1 du code pénal pour
clarifier la responsabilité de l'auteur
d'un délit ou d'un crime ayant
volontairement consommé de l'alcool ou
des stupéfiants
une idée déjà porté en janvier 2020 par
la sénatrice nathalie goulet à
l'initiative d'une proposition de loi
sur le sujet pour l'élu de l'orne
le gouvernement essaie opportunément de
reprendre à son compte les travaux du
sénat
si le gouvernement aujourd'hui être
efficace il peut soutenir les textes du
sénat voir les améliorer parce que on
n'est jamais à l'abri une amélioration
mais doubler le travail du sénat je
trouve que c'est un travail de coucou et
c'est lamentable
le texte de nathalie goulet sera débattu
en séance publique le 25 mai prochain au
sénat hasard de calendrier
le projet de loi d'eric dupond-moretti
devrait être présenté en conseil des
ministres presque au même moment avec
nous pour le match des idées ce soir et
la kribi romdhane bienvenue vous êtes
porte-parole de générations conseillère
et
lionel d'ile-de-france conseillère
municipale de massy c'est dans l'essonne
bienvenue également à ferghana diaries
vous êtes délégué général de l'académie
libre des sciences humaines et
consultant en politique publique merci à
tous les deux d'être avec nous ferghana
ziari eric dupond moretti a t-il raison
faut-il combler un vide juridique est ce
que l' affaire halimi la sphère sarah
halimi a montré qu'il y avait des files
grave dans notre droit
écoutez bon à part je suis pas un
spécialiste du droit mais j'avoue être
mal à l'aise quant à la politisation à
outrance d'une affaire qui me semblent
davantage médical que juridique
on a beaucoup dit dans les médias que
les juges avaient octroyé une sorte de
permis de tuer pour des gens qui avaient
consommé des stupéfiants
ce n'est pas le cas quand on lit les
expertises en tout cas le témoignage des
experts des psychiatres qui ont examiné
l'assassin de madame halimi il s'agit
bien de préciser que nous avions là à
faire un individu ou qui avait perdu son
âme aille à des expertises deux conclu à
l'abolition du discernement conclu à
l'altération du discernement donc il y
avait une possibilité d'interprétation
il ya une décision prise il ya quand
même eu un des décollages sont
majoritairement statuer sur le fait que
la sacem n'avait plus son discernement
alors effectivement on peut toujours
remettre en question cette décision mais
dans ce cas là on se situe sur le
terrain de la santé et de la médecine
est pas du droit c'est à dire que moi
j'aurais bien aimé avoir éventuellement
le témoignage ou en tout cas la remise
en question de médecins pour relever
d'une question qu'est ce qui relève de
la psychiatrie
or la psychiatrie n'est ni de droite ni
de gauche est une discipline médicale et
dont je suis j'avoue un peu mal à l'aise
non aucun intérêt donc je ne pense que
la nouvelle loi serait en effet initié
il n'aurait pas beaucoup de valeur
ajoutée en l'occurrence intéressant sur
ce sujet de lire l'interview de françois
molins ce qui va alimenter la discussion
et je vous donne la parole dans un sens
c'est à lire dans le monde vendredi il
est désormais procureur général près de
la cour de cassation est lui aussi dit
comme vous fergane rien ne permet
d'affirmer que la justice serait laxiste
la justice ne délivre aucun permis de
tuer mais dit-il l'émotion suscitée par
cette décision révèle sans doute que la
loi n'est pas adapté il met juste en
garde le parlement contre la tentation
de légiférer dans l'urgence et sous le
coup de l'émotion et la kribi romdhane
est-ce que l'émotion que l'on voit que
l'on constate ne doit pas nous pousser à
revoir notre droit oui c'est surtout moi
moi je veux quand même commencé par dire
que je partage cette émotion parce que
c'est d'abord une idée c'est un
assassinat barbare auquel auquel nous
avons collectivement assisté évidemment
qu'on ne peut être que solidaires de la
famille de sarah
alimi à tous ceux qui d'une certaine
manière s'identifient à cette dame
moi je rejoins néanmoins le propos qui
consiste à dire que je veux à la fois
faire confiance à la justice et faire
confiance aux experts psychiatres qui se
sont exprimés et quand il s'agit d'un
problème de santé il faut aussi leucate
avec le caractériser comme tel ce qui
n'empêche pas que cette collecte qui a
été commis et les médecins eux mêmes ont
reconnu et considéré comme étant un acte
antisémite mais c'est important d'avoir
ça en dette c'est à dire qu'il ne s'agit
à aucun moment de nier le caractère
antisémite de l'acte qui a été commis
mais de constater sur le plan médical
que à se moquer de ces moments là il
n'était pas dans son état normal et que
ça n'est pas que le cannabis qui a
suscité cet état c'est qu'il y avait un
terrain
à l'origine qui a fait le cannabis est
venue amplifier les taps de monsieur
traoré à ce moment là donc j'ai le droit
de jorf l'été selon vous ou en tout cas
se faire l'écho d'une émotion populaire
qui a l'impression que la justice la
défend mal ou la défendra mal à l'avenir
avec une telle décision je ne crois pas
que le rôle de la justice et de se
soumettre à l'applaudimètre c'est à dire
que nous sommes dans un état de droit et
d une législation qui est répressive à
juste titre et qui condamne le meurtre
mais de la même manière que vous voyez
c'est comme si vous posiez la question
de savoir si telle ou telle personne
doit être placée sous tutelle ou
curatelle sous sauvegarde de justice
cette question-là n'appartient pas aux
juristes n'appartient pas au citoyen
lambda c'est une question qui est
purement scientifique et la science ne
doit pas se mettre à ce devra se faire à
l'applaudimètre
pas plus que la justice donc le propos
que vous avez rapporté qui consiste à
dire que l'émotion légitime un
changement de législation et françois 5
et 10 et apparentés qui est bien sûr
laisser cette saison plus grave je crois
que oui il est tentant de se soumettre
effectivement à la dictature de
l'émotion et des médias mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi savoir gare raison
garder et dire que face à un état de
droit certaines décisions peuvent nous
révolter peuvent nous paraître
scandaleuse mais il est important de
bien séparer la justice de l'émotion
populaire directe après table un coma gg
quand même lui un pas de chez moi c'est
intéressant dans un dans un journal
récemment où il y avait vraiment un
effort de pédagogie du docteur bensussan
expert musical sur marianne ou du coup
ça nous a permis aussi de comprendre au
fond ce que ce que l'on veut en tant que
citoyens y compris l'émotion populaire
elle nous amène à vouloir que l'individu
soit sanctionné et qui soit pas libre de
2,2 d'abord de porter n'importe quels
atouts de récidiver aujourd'hui il est
enfermé dans une unité psychiatrique et
il se trouve que son irresponsabilité
enfin cet enfermement il amène à être
enfermés probablement plus longtemps au
regard de sa situation
psychiatrique que s'il avait dû être
détenus donc l'essentiel c'est quand
même que cet individu soit enfermé et
mis hors d'état de nuire et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
autre thème à voir avec vous ce soir les
réactions fortes à cette tribune de
militaires publié dans valeurs actuelles
elle est intitulée ainsi pour un retour
de l'honneur de nos gouvernants 20
généraux appel macron à défendre le
patriotisme je voulais quelques passages
forts que j'ai retenu notre honneur
aujourd'hui tient dans la dénonciation
du délitement qui frappe notre patrie
délitement qui à travers un certain anti
racisme s'affiche dans un seul but créer
sur notre sol un mal-être délitement qui
avec l'islamisme et les hordes de
banlieue entraîne le détachement de
multiples parcelles de la nation
délitement car la haine prend le pas sur
la fraternité lors de manifestations ou
le pouvoir utilise les forces de l'ordre
comme agents supplétifs et bouc
émissaire c'est un vrai coup de gueule
que pousse une partie de l'armée et cela
provoque beaucoup beaucoup de réactions
politiques je vais vous demander votre
avis dans un instant on va d'abord
accueillir dans le match des idées jean
daniel lévy bonsoir vous êtes directeur
délégué de harris interactive france
c'est une prise de position très franche
de la part de de l'armée c'est assez
rare pour être signalé est ce que cela
peut avoir un impact sur l'opinion des
français est ce que la vie de l'armée
compte pour les français c'est que nous
sommes face à des tas sanguines sont si
je ne me trompe pas plus en activité en
tant que tel mais qui sont déplacés nos
retraités et qui s'exprime par n'importe
où mais qui s'exprime dans un journal
qui s'appelle valeur actuelle qui est un
journal qui se positionne à droite voire
très à droite sur l'échiquier politique
donc à une forme de cohérence entre ce
que une peuvent être est le média qui
utilisent pour poids exprimé à cet avis
le deuxième aspect c'est que malgré tout
d'une manière générale on est habitués
en france a fait en sorte que l'armée
soit la grande
muette comme on dit c'est à dire qu'ils
n'expliquent pas d'orientation d'idées
politiques ou de positionnement par
rapport aux orientations de l'exécutif
et 2 qu'elle soit au service du pouvoir
politique et qu'elle ne soit pas en
pression à l'égard du pouvoir politique
et c'est là où la chose est nouvelle
elle est nouvelle parce qu'en fait ce
sont des personnes qui s'expriment à
visage des trucs découvert deux ailes
nouvelle parce qu'elle s'exprime avec
une orientation qui laisse entrevoir qui
aurait une forme de chienlit si vous me
permettez cette expression dans la cité
française
et puis enfin lé nouvel le parce qu'elle
indique que si ce n'est à eux d'autres
personnes qui font partie de comme 10 de
l'actif donc c'est à dire des personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui dans une activité
serait susceptible de me ramener l'ordre
sur notre territoire si jamais la
situation de m amener à dégénérer le
fait que ces généreux soit soutenue
ensuite par marine le pen est très
critiqué par la gauche et même recadré
par la ministre des armées florence
parly ça peut profiter à qui ou ça peut
les et qui ça peut inévitablement
profiter à marine le pen a emmené dans
un contexte quand vous interrogez les
électeurs qui sont le plus à droite sur
l'échiquier politique les électeurs qui
ont l'intention de voter en faveur de
marine le pen ou ceux qui la regarde de
manière positive déclare d'une manière
générale que elle dit attendre qu'il y
ait plus d'autorité de la place de
l'état et que cette tribune qui signés
s'inscrit clairement dans cette
orientation là avec la perception que il
ya de la part du crédit donnent la
réplique une forme de laxisme
on peut rappeler qu'au cours de la
dernière campagne présidentielle
la thématique de la sécurité il n'était
loin s'en faut la première des priorités
elle était en dixième onzième position
que même parmi l'électorat d'emmanuel
macron il s'agissait d'une modalité qui
apparaissait comme étant annexe le
président de la république n'avait que
très peu parlé dans le cas de sa
campagne électorale
en revanche qu'il s'agissait d'une
dimension structurante pour les
électeurs du rassemblement national et
qui constitue aujourd'hui un point
absolument sensible de la part de cet
électorat là
qui plus est quand on prend un tribunal
qui est amené à parler notamment de la
montée de l'islam politique et de
l'islamisme dont il 2
évolue dans un univers qui est
profondément favorable à ce qui est
indiqué par eux marine le pen a tout
dernier mot jean daniel lévy avant de
répartir la parole en plateau
historiquement on sait pour qui votent
plutôt les militaires on sait quelle est
la tendance de leurs votes
c'est une tendance qui est à droite
voire très à droite alors il suffit de
regarder en fonction des endroits en
fait où il y à des casernes qui sont
implantées comment se structure le
comportement électoral et avec un
comportement électoral de fort soutien à
l'égard de marine le pen ou à l'égard du
rassemblement national voire 1
anciennement du front national c'est un
électorat qui considère d'une manière
générale qu'ils ont un très fort
attachement à la patrie qu'ils ont un
très fort attachement à la république
qu'ils ont un très fort attachement à
l'ordre à la sécurité et ce sont des
termes qui ne sont évidemment pas
hégémonique pour leur assemblée
nationale lorca qui colle assez bien
avec les thématiques qui sont prises en
charge par leur assemblée nationale donc
à une forme de cohérence globale comme
vous l'avez indiqué expression de la
part de militaires au sein de valeurs
actuelles
réponse de la part de marine le pen par
rapport à cette tribune là et puis une
difficulté exprimée de la part d'un côté
dans un premier temps du gouvernement
avec une réaction soumettrons pas deux
jours après la tribune de la part de
plantes par lille ministre des armées et
des réactions indignées de la part de la
gauche
donc il ne semble pas accréditer cette
thèse et qu'il faudrait ramener l'ordre
à travers un pouvoir politique ou un
pouvoir militaire relativement fort jean
daniel lévy rester avec année je vais
revenir vers vous si quelque chose vous
fait réagir en plateau et la kribi
ramdam
elle vous interpelle cette tribune elle
vous choque qu'elle vous indigne que moi
je suis profondément
en digne et mêmes terrorisé par le ton
adopté dans cette tribune à la fois par
la description que ces messieurs font de
la société une description très clivée
clivante de la société qui oppose les
populations les unes aux autres voire
qui stigmatise une part de la population
considérant que les habitants des
quartiers populaires seraient tous
islamistes c'est un peu ce qui nous est
dit en filigrane sur les raisons qui
sont qui sont évoqués et puis je suis
très choquée parce que je je je crois
qu'il ya un putschiste dans cette dans
cette tribune
et c'est là on a c'est le ton dans kof
qui pourraient être adoptées
quand on quand on prévoit un coup d'état
et je le dis avec beaucoup de sincérité
c'est une attente à la république là où
nous essayons tous bords confondus
d'être comment dire
attachez les garants des valeurs
républicaines et désillusions en tout
cas et d'aisance états unis mais je
crois qu'il faut faire preuve de
concorde républicaine quand on parle de
république et des institutions et en
l'occurrence ce sont les institutions
qui sont attaqués et je crois que alors
même parny a mis un peu de temps à
réagir mais n'est alors l'agent elle a
réagi qu'on attend c'est aussi une
réaction de l'elysée avec des attaques
telles que celle ci est surtout que
l'exécutif se saisisse du sujet et qu'il
saisisse le procureur de la république
parce qu'on peut pas laisser faire
laisser dire n'importe quoi y compris
dans la presse par des messieurs qui
sont supposés respecter un devoir de
réserve les mots de florence parly sont
ceux là les armées ne sont pas là pour
faire campagne mais pour défendre la
france ferghana ziari alors je suis
aussi d'accord avec la plupart des
propos tenus ici je trouve que cette
tribune ait de très mauvais goût
attention néanmoins à ne pas surestimer
la stature des signataires de la tribune
et c'est là où je suis pas d'accord vous
quand vous dites qu'il faut que l'élysée
réagi ce serait aussi donner peut-être
trop d'importance et de stature à des
gens qui rappelons le sont à la retraite
donc il s'agit pas de l'armée en tant
que corps officiels il s'agit des
officiers retraités parmi eux vous avez
des signataires donc me christian
piquemal qui a été radié
il faut le dire aussi de deux de l'armée
si je ne dis pas de bêtises donc je
comprend la réticence du gouvernement
ont pu avoir une parole forte à ce
serait peut-être aussi légitimé et
donner trop d'importance à une tribune
qui est certes désagréable mais qui
n'est peut-être pas aussi porté par des
gens si important que ça sur le fond on
vous avez raison c'est une tribune de
très mauvais goût le symbole est quand
même assez mal choisi puisque cette
tribune est publiée
soixante ans après le putsch d'alger
donc que voulait signifier ces gens qui
ont écrit cette tribune est
cette tribune a ceci de pervers qu'elle
mélange à la fois des constats qu'on
peut faire le danger islamiste et en
même temps amalgames ce danger avec on
va dire de la politique partisane
amalgamer et mettre dans un même panier
les islamistes et ceux qui critiquent un
certain roman national voilà moi je
trouve ça un petit peu indécent on va
dire que la cause de la république
mérite un peu mieux que ce genre de
prise de parole
un dernier mot jean daniel lévy avant
qu'on vous laisse et entièrement à ce
qui a été indiqué précédemment c'est à
dire qu'on est dans cette situation où
les français sont abordés
concernant la situation en matière de
sécurité que au cours des dernières
élections municipales il s'agit c'est la
première préoccupation était françaises
et des français et que globalement quand
vous regardiez en termes de structure
électorale s'était clairement plus des
électeurs qui était à droite que à
gauche sur l'échiquier politique donc il
a probablement la volonté de mettre un
enjeu supplémentaire à un an de la
campagne électorale avant l'élection
présidentielle pour faire en sorte que
la sécurité deviennent plus encore eu un
thème central du débat politique on voit
que c'est pour partir quand on voit que
j'avais bertrand en parle de manière
assez régulière on voit que emmanuel
macron a pris fait et cause la
thématique de la sécurité on peut voir
également en fait et qu'il en est
question de manière assez fréquentes
dans les différents médias et que donc
dans ce contexte là c'est la volonté tu
as quoi cette thématique là et de
l'inscrire de manière honnête dans le
cas de la campagne présidentielle
pas uniquement en vente et de faire un
putsch comme on pourrait le croire mais
plus pour faire une pression de pin au
napalm et globale voilà donc pour cette
tribune merci jean daniel lévy d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées un autre
propos qui n'est pas loin d'être aussi
un coup de gueule c'est celui de jean
marc ayrault dans un entretien à
l'agencé france presse l'ancien premier
ministre est aujourd'hui président de la
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
et à la veille du lancement du mois des
mémoires il s'inquiète je le cite
entre ceux qui veulent qu'on ne touche à
rien et ceux qui nous entraîne sur des
approches racialiste indigéniste qui ne
sent pas acceptable non plus il y a une
voix il y a un chemin
si on veut une société apaisée libéré
qui se retrouvent dans une mémoire
commune c'est fondamental d'emprunter ce
chemin plutôt que celui de la
radicalisation de la polarisation de la
caricature ou de la négation ferghana
ziari je souscris aux propos de jean
marc ayrault le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que l'histoire est prise en étau
entre deux mouvements qui s'alimentent
mutuellement vous avez d'un côté une
extrême gauche qui utilisent les péchés
historique de l'occident et de
l'association française pour lui mettre
finalement sur le dos tous les maux de
la terre ce qui est un petit peu
réducteur et vous avez aussi à droite
une tendance à se satisfaire un peu trop
d erreurs qui auraient été commises par
les grandes figures par exemple du
colonialisme républicain par aussi
certaines zones certains hommes d'état
sous l'ancien régime on pense à la
polémique sur colbert et sur louis xiv
de de l'année dernière je pense qu'il
vit en effet une place entre pour une
dire une approche lucide sans être né en
manichéen sur cette tendance parfois
qu'on voit dans les mouvements des
coloniaux à faire par exemple de
l'esclavagé de la traite négrière un
crime qui serait qui relaieraient du
monopole de l'occident d'ailleurs la loi
taubira est assez problématique sur ce
point puisqu'elle ne vise en réalité que
certains types d' esclavage alors même
que l'on gagnerait je crois à rappeler
que ce fléau est un fléau qui touche
toutes les sociétés humaines qu'encore
aujourd'hui dans les sociétés extra
occidental vous avez des esclaves on l'a
vu en libye avec ces images assez
indigne de personnes vendu par par des
parts des locaux donc il faut je crois
avoir une approche critique de
l'histoire sans pour autant tomber dans
les excès que l'on entend régulièrement
aux deux extrémités de l'échiquier
politique
or là d'après jean-marc car on a deux
camps elle à kribi
écoutez je veux parler de choses très
concrètes
moi hier dimanche 25 avril je célébrais
dans ma ville je commémoré dans ma ville
le jour du souvenir de la déportation et
chaque année lors de ces commémorations
on constate à quel point travail de
mémoire est essentiel parce qu'il ya des
choses qu'il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
faut pouvoir transmettre les anciens
combattants vont disparaître
malheureusement et ils commencent déjà à
disparaître et mais ce travail de
mémoire cet héritage il faut qu'on garde
pour ne plus jamais reproduire les
erreurs qu'on a pu commettre
il y à quelques décennies c'est pas si
loin que ça ben moi je pense que sur l'
esclavage sur la colonisation
il faut qu'on assume et qu'on fasse ce
travail de mémoire
je souscris à léquilibre qu'essaye de de
danse dans stahl et jean marc ayrault
entre les extrêmes d'un côté et de
l'autre moi je crois que c'est dans la
nuance
on peut trouver une réponse dans la
subtilité et on peut pas mettre les gens
alors moi je je je je ne suis pas du nid
du conde et indigéniste sans nier qu'il
existe des discriminations et qu'elles
sont évidemment parfois inspiré
l'histoire familiale culturelle etc
nous avons les uns et des autres tout
son héritage qui irriguent notre
éducation notre voilà donc tout ça
existe évidemment mais de l'autre côté
je peignais complètement
il faut pas non plus nier ce qui se
produit dans la société français mais
toute la question est là
cet équilibre mois de jean marc ayrault
me plaît bien il faut et je trouve qu'on
peine à apporter des réponses concrètes
moi j'entendais le présent macron
pendant sa campagne présidentielle
insisté lourdement sur ces sujets là y
compris sur la colonisation etc
et moi je ne vois pas de d'avancées
majeures en fait et la question de
l'enseignement dans les programmes
scolaires de cette époque de la deûle
esclavage elle est fondamentale pourquoi
les réserver aujourd'hui uniquement aux
français ultramarins et pourquoi est
elle réservée au lycée professionnel et
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose
d'incohérent chose qui cloche est pas la
question c'est ce qu'il faut choisir ce
qu'il faut un peu picorer dans notre
histoire ce qui mérite d'être gardé en
mémoire et ce qu'ils devraient être
jetés à la poubelle pour valérie
pécresse c'est non elle réagit c'est
justement aux propos d' emmanuel macron
qui parlait du fait de déconstruire
notre histoire notre propre histoire
on l'écouté je vous fait réagir après
l'histoire de france elle se prend en
bloc il ya des millions de français qui
ont choisi de l'être qui ne l'était pas
au départ qui ont choisi de l'être parce
que la france était un idéal parce que
notre histoire elle est belle parce que
elle a beaucoup plus d'image lumineuse
que deux pages sombres
alors moi je crois que le rôle d'un
président de la république s'est pas de
déconstruire l'histoire de france je
pense le rôle d'un président de la
république c'est d'incarner la fierté
nationale parce que c'est derrière la
fierté nationale qu'on rassemble un
peuple et c'est avec la fierté nationale
qu'on intègre ferghana diaries est ce
que ça abîme la cohésion nationale de
trop critiquer vous parliez d'un regard
critique sur l'histoire et sur la
mémoire mais de ne voir que ce qui a été
mal fait est ce que ça fait du mal à
notre nation
il faut avoir un discours équilibré moi
je ne suis pas convaincu que la critique
du roman national fera marcher n'en soit
vous savez la capacité d'une
civilisation a progressé à apprendre de
ses erreurs
dépend de la vivacité des critiques
internes à la civilisation
même au temps des réseaux sociaux même
au temps des réseaux sociaux je crois
pas que ce soit quelque chose qu'il
faille bannir savez moi en tant que
libéral par exemple je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on continue à aduler des
figures comme louis xiv comme comme
colbert alors on me dit toujours qu'il
faut pas être anachronique faut pas
projeté sur le passé les jours dit le
21e siècle et je pense que ceux qui ont
ce discours précisément ont une histoire
un peu une vision un peu étriqué de
l'histoire de l'occident
il faut savoir que le plus vieux
réquisitoire contre l' esclavage dans
l'occident chrétien vous l'avez au ivème
siècle après jésus-christ donc sous la
plume de quelqu'un comme grégoire de
nysse alors la critique la plus vieille
critique de l'impérialisme occidental
vous l'avez au xvième siècle sous la
plume de ce qu'on a à tout ce qu'on a
appelé l'école de salamanque qui des
théologiens espagnol qui critiquait
justement les exactions des
missionnaires espagnols dans les
amériques
tout le 17ème le xviiième et xixème
siècles sont parsemés de critiques de la
colonisation et de l'esclavagé donc à
l'époque déjà vous aviez des figures
intellectuelles tu qu'ils étaient
capables de distinguer le juste et de
l'injuste de sorte qu on est en droit
d'avoir un regard donc faire confiance
alors faire confiance à sa population
will 38 ans à la population tout en
rappelant aussi effectivement que
l'occident s'il a péché à de multiples
reprises comme toutes les civilisations
l'esclavagé sous les n'a aucune couleur
de peau c'est un fléau qui est universel
la différence néanmoins c'est que
l'europe a été la première à abolir
cette institution le mouvement
abolitionniste et à d'abord un mouvement
européen c'est ce que rappelait
notamment l'historien olivier pétré
comme mieux dans son ouvrage on les
traite négrière
donc il faut aussi rappeler que nous
avons été à l'avant-garde finalement de
ces critiques qui ont permis d'améliorer
l'état des libertés publiques
là où encore aujourd'hui certaines
civilisations je n'ai pas les nommer
mais pratique des encore le despotisme
sur leur population un tout dernier
moyenne à crémines romaine sur ce point
où on passe aux derniers sujets non mais
moi je veux pas rentrer dans
dans cette polémique là je crois qu'il
ya effectivement un équilibre à trouver
je rentre pas non plus dans les grandes
phrases de propagande électorale de
madame pécresse parce que tout ça c'est
des grands mots concrètement c'est ce
sont des générations qu'il faut outiller
et connaître son histoire c'est
essentiel pour pouvoir avancer et faire
avancer la société
la république la nation la patrie donc
c'est aussi ce dont on parle et je crois
que c'est ce que dit jean marc ayrault
l'histoire avec ses bons et ses mauvais
continûment dernier thème de ce match
c'est la boulette puis les excuses
d'europe écologie les verts après un
visuel polémique pour pousser les jeunes
à s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
en vue des régionales je vous entends
rien vous allez me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans un instant leur arrivée
appelle ça la bourde anti-vieux de
julien bayou regardez c'est dans son
édition de ce matin l'un des visuels on
le voit un petit peu puis retiré disait
ceci les boumeurs eux ont prévu d'aller
voter
sous-entendu si j'ai bien compris allez
voter aussi pour faire contrepoids aux
votes des vieux qui ne serait pas écolo
peut-être que j'ai mal compris
en tout cas excuses très rapide de
julien bayou dans ce communiqué le
visuel boomer était maladroit et
blessant nous l'avons immédiatement
retiré je ne l'avais pas validé mais
j'en prends la responsabilité la faire
et elle réglée écoutez moi je les ai
vécus de l'intérieur donc rien juste que
vous dire exactement la manière dont ça
s'est passé dans mon bac technique
pardon bug technique comme c'est
absolument en fait tu te le visuel est
resté pas été publié pendant quelques
minutes je suis candidate
il a été créé c'est pas ton séjour
il a été créé par des équipes de quand
parfois une personne faisant partie
d'une équipe de campagne et publié
immédiatement ce à quoi nous avons
collectivement réagi en disant que
personne ne comprendrait ce que ça veut
dire boomer et que l'interprétation
immédiate c'est à dire c'est les gens
nés pendant le baby boom
parce que au premier degré c'est ça
évidemment pour les gens qui ont créé le
visuel c'est pas ça boomers c'est un
état d'esprit avant d'être une classe
d'âge
ceci dit ça a été ça a été supprimé tout
de suite moi ce que je veux quand même
dire c'est que cette terre des réseaux
sociaux elle amène à ce que dans les
cinq minutes les gens fassent des
captures d'écran et fassent vivre un peu
n'a pas droit à l'erreur
enfin depuis trente ans qu'il n'existe
pas enfin c'est à dire que si le si si
le visuel avait existé pendant quelques
heures ou quelques huées journée sur les
réseaux sociaux
je dis pas un il aurait fallu là c'est
quelques minutes est tout de suite c'est
la capture d'écran qui est utilisé
pendant trois jours pourris on embrasse
aussi pour taper lundi que c'est quand
même un indicateur aujourd'hui je crois
que les écologistes font peur d'une
certaine manière parce que je constate
dans la presse et partout en france que
ce sont les principales cibles du
discours politique à droite et
malheureusement aussi d'une partie de la
gauche il reste très peu de temps
pardonnez-moi ferghana ziri oui alors
moi j'ai trouvé l'indignation des partis
politiques un petit peu hypocrite parce
qu'on sait bien que tous les partis
politiques sont allés à l'école de catch
me qui disait que la spécificité du
politique était la discrimination entre
l'ami et l'ennemi dont chaque camp
politique se fabrique quelque part un
petit peu son ennemi la droite c'est
d'immigrés la gauche et le riche
le centre l'extrême centre de macron
c'est la france qui fument des clopes et
roulent au diesel vont lagat les
écologistes ont tenté de ces biais les
boumeurs alors moi je vous avoue que bon
je ne suis pas ça sympathisants
écologistes et je n'adhère pas à leur
communication mais au regard des
standards acte médiatique actuel ça ne
m'a pas choqué ceci dit je trouve que
c'est dommage d'avoir évacué un sujet
important c'est que ce visuel il possède
néanmoins une question qui n'est jamais
abordé ces sept d'inégalités
intergénérationnel savez c'est en 2013
c'est hakim el karoui qui travaille à
l'institut montaigne qui n'est pas
réputé être le think tank le plus
gauchiste le plus radical du spectre
politique
qui avait publié la lutte des agents en
faisant le constat que l'état providence
tel qu'il a été conçu après la seconde
guerre mondiale eh bien tant d à se
retourner contre les générations futures
en leur léguant une montagne de dettes
et des chars notamment un système de
retraite déséquilibré qui pesait sur les
jeunes actifs et qui fait que la
pauvreté avait changé de camp
il aurait été intelligent d'aborder ce
sujet là bas c'est dommage qu'on puisse
pas approfondir on le fera une prochaine
fois peut-être merci en tout cas à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce match
des idées en direct sur public sénat
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent demain à 18 heures et à 22
heures 30 pour un nouveau numéro en
attendant vous avez rendez vous avec
bonjour chez vous dès 7h30 au
rayonnement de chimie recevra notamment
najat vallaud belkacem ancien ministre
socialiste et tête de liste en auvergne
rhône-alpes pour les prochaines
régionales
excellente soirée